hi-yah my name is Francisco Tomas key
and I'm not gonna be talking about
transpiling yes if that's in the
schedule the speaker says the real name
of my talk which is the browsers and
feature complete but surprise I'm not
talking about that either
I actually didn't change my talk for
like a third time I just came up with a
better name like at the time I thought
of this name was just kind of a jumble
of ideas as was the best thing I could
come up with but this is what I actually
want to talk about and it is the
Internet as an incremental skill and
it's kind of about like my journey in
becoming a programmer through the web
and the original inspiration for this
came from another talk by David Nolan
and it's to talk about closure script
actually he gave it a Texas je s but at
the beginning of his talk he focused a
lot on the importance of consoles and
how that was super important in him
becoming a programmer specifically I
think his first computer was like an
Apple 2 or something and that thing
fundamentally worked like a console in
that like the way you interacted with it
was basically programming and how he
feels that consoles are important today
still and I agree with that because even
though my first computer was not an
Apple 2 I also kind of started with
computers with a console only my console
looked like this but that's a lie right
my console actually looked like this
yeah my girlfriend actually like went
and installed OS 9 and Netscape 7 just
to get that screen shot so there you go
and yeah back then there was no console
right like literally everything had to
be like a stream of alerts and there was
no like disable any more alerts it was a
fun time to program but so I kind of
want to take you back to this time which
was you know around 1998-99 and give you
a sense of how I kind of developed my
programming skills through just kind of
using the web so at the time I was like
a teenager and you know teenagers have
things to say and one of the outlets to
say stuff is live journal for me wasn't
actually live journal for me it was the
Mac addict forums because I was super
pissed that they made AI tools
like a pay service after they promised
this would be free for life so mag
addict and then later on you know
another way to express yourself was of
course myspace and the really
interesting thing about like these
services these like I don't know what to
call them social slash talky services
was that at the time we hadn't really
made like really nice in browser editors
right like or like WYSIWYG like you know
make things bold or whatever and either
by design like in live journals case or
by accident in MySpace's case people
started to figure out that you can make
your post more interesting if you use
kind of this magic text called HTML so
you know if you went and posted on lots
of forums they weren't sanitizing HTML
yet so you could like kind of throw in
some tags and like you know things would
start doing crazy stuff or in the case
of like MySpace you could like change
the entire page right and this was
really interesting in my opinion because
it's a kind of a cool approach to a
problem that I think is really hard
which is syntax I think if you're a
programmer you kind of forget how hard
the initial syntax steps are of like you
really got to make that thing a hundred
percent correct or the computer is just
gonna do nothing and this was very
different right because HTML is really
forgiving so when you went and you were
kind of like just copy pasting random
things from like either view source or
your friend would say like hey if you
paste this into like your MySpace it'll
turn your background into like some
crazy image you could kind of get away
with not getting it a hundred percent
right and more importantly not fully
understanding even what you're doing
right someone pasted you something you
put it in it's kind of like a little
piece of magic that you put into this
existing site and also like HTML was a
lot easier to back then right like I
think this really speaks to a lot of
people who are programmers right like a
lot of people know what fonts are so if
I say font color equals red like they
kind of get the sense that that'll make
it read and there even need to close the
tag and if you wanted to be black later
you just open a new tag and just keep
opening tags and whatever right and the
coolest part about this was that like
that that's not the end of like the
journey right like that's
point someone figured out that there's
even more magical tags you can kind of
add this onclick thing and then it might
actually do some dynamic things right so
going from kind of like just posting
nonsense on the web to like posting
nonsense that like does crazy stuff was
kind of like this really easy
incremental step and if you don't wanted
to take kind of the next step and like
you know just having a live journal or
whatever wasn't enough that was also
kind of easy right because there were
like these services like geo cities or
if you like went to college like you
know they gave you a free like place to
host your site or you know it I don't
know if this is true anymore but like at
least at this time every ISP kind of
also gave you like a free website or
whatever like bars was adelphia but like
you know people had their AOL pages or
whatever and so going from kind of just
learning to throw HTML at like existing
websites to making your own website was
also kind of easy especially because
again HTML is really forgiving and kind
of like any strings more or less valid
HTML so you could like grab like the
HTML right from a post and put it in
like a document and that would be kind
of the start of a webpage and you didn't
really need to understand anything about
servers or anything like I remember when
I was doing this like the way it worked
was it was just like literally like a
file upload button and you would upload
your HTML files and that's actually how
I learned about zip files like I came
from a map world and it was all stuff
that expander and like I was like why
can't I upload folders this is
ridiculous technology and so I was like
no zips man oh ok so this process was
like really natural and a lot of my
friends had websites a lot more than I
think would today actually and in fact
even my dad who doesn't do anything
technology at all he's a microbiologist
I also had a website and again his
understanding was this kind of gray area
of like you know I've stolen different
parts from different sites and kind of
put this thing together this would be
like before the age of minification so
that still kind of worked right that was
still like feasible and then the best
part of all right is that once you had
this thing on a server a lot of servers
already had like PHP installed so are
this
this other even more magical tag that
did kind of more stuff so this
transition was like really natural right
like the font tag which I totally
understand right like oh I can set a
color to like unclick which like kind of
speaks to me Oh what is it gonna do well
on click it'll do something to like this
kind of crazy tag that like will do
survery stuff and that's definitely the
way I felt about those things like oh I
didn't like really fully understand what
was going on with a PHP but like I could
copy/paste enough to get by and so this
is kind of what I call this incremental
skill where like going from doing easy
stuff to hard stuff is kind of like a
spectrum and there's kind of a lot of
really interesting properties about each
step in the spectrum you know each step
kind of builds from the last right in
each step kind of like is perhaps a
little harder than it needs to be again
like posting in like livejournal with
like HTML tags is definitely harder than
using like a really nice web editor but
that little bit of learning kind of pays
dividends later because it puts your
foot into like the next step and not
only that but each step is also like its
own conclusion if you want right like if
you stop in the middle it's fine like
you haven't wasted any time like any one
of these steps if that's like the end of
your journey you still have like a lot
of really useful I guess skills to do
exactly those things that you tried to
do so basically each step kind of like
adds immediate value now so another way
to think about it is kind of like you
know going from reading the web to
writing the web is kind of this natural
transition and then another way to look
at it it's kind of like you start up as
a user and then you kind of abuse the
web right like a you find ways to like
change things in your sites and
eventually you create with the web and
then perhaps a more politically correct
ways to say you're kind of like a pro
user and once I kind of started thinking
about that process of learning to
program that I went through I kind of
saw it in a lot of other things and the
other big one I saw it in was Ti
calculators which was kind of the other
big way I learned how to program
and you know math class at some point
you know you got to shell out a hundred
bucks and buy this thing and the really
cool thing about the ti calculators is
that it kind of has this different
accidental super-successful approach to
syntax which is that every line that you
type into the calculator to get a result
is actually a valid line of Basic and
you don't even know that when you're
using it and so even if you're not
programming you're starting to get a
handle for what the computer wants right
like if you just have one line of code
or one line of I don't know math and you
forget a parenthesis or something and
you get an error you start to build this
intuition for like oh I really do need
to always close my parentheses right and
it's really easy to deal with the error
when it's just one line as opposed to
like if you're just learning programming
you've got ten lines it's like error and
you're like oh I don't know right like
here you type one line it says uh uh
then you go back okay I see and the
tricks you learn in like building the or
like using the calculator again kind of
help you secretly become kind of a
programmer right like one of the first
steps in like becoming a better ti-83
user is that hey you know the first time
you get like a problem wrong because
like you duplicated the same thing twice
right in that second line instead of
storing it to a variable then it's
eventually someone's like no no no just
store it and then like then you can use
it later and you've just kind of
accidentally learned variables right and
then something happens where you
discover that TI programs can have our
sorry Ti calculators can have programs
either that's because your teachers like
hey download this math program or more
likely because you downloaded Tetris but
ii like the spark goes off in your mind
that TI e calculators have programs
there's always some crafty student in
the class who figures out that ok fine
programs but you know what programs are
just kind of this place we can write
text so i don't know what a program
necessarily does but i know it can use
it to cheat right and the crazy thing
about this is that this is almost a
functioning program right like what
you've done is just typed in a formula
but the step from going like
hey I can use my calculator to cheat -
hey the calculator can cheat for me is
not that big of a step right so I think
this look definitely follows this kind
of like same spectrum right like there's
this definite like abuse section in the
middle and then you start off just using
it and then by the end you've kind of
accidentally learned how to program not
because you set out to be a programmer
but because at every single step you
were offered a little bit of value if
you just put in a little bit of work and
that and I kind of want to compare that
to like you know if you say I'm gonna
become a programmer and then like if you
stop after like class - but like an
online class you know how to draw a
bunch of circles or something as opposed
to like no I have I have like if you
stop at the tetris stage then you know
how to use the calculator you know how
to store variables and you know how to
play Tetris as opposed to like having
this weird random I know how to draw
circles in this one API like skill so
user Pro user and creator and kind of
what I want to get across is that that
middle section I think is super
important this kind of like making
people pro users before they become
creators sure lots people have heard of
hyper card this is a system that was
designed I think very much with this
kind of incremental step in mind you
start off using hyper card it's kind of
just like a note-taking program and then
very slowly you can add features like oh
I have lots of cards I can add some
navigation stuff and kind of
incrementally end up with like a fully
functioning program and then obviously I
think reading and writing is the best
example of this kind of incremental
thing where it's really hard to learn
how to read without also learning how to
write right you know just you learn the
letters you learn how to read and you
can probably throw together a sign that
says like sale coffee or something even
if it's kind of misspelled again in the
same way that even like if you use the
wrong HTML tags or you don't do
everything a hundred percent correct you
can still start getting value out of it
really early so I want to compare this
kind of like I don't know strategy of
learning or method of learning to
something else which I call the like
appliance style of learning and I want
to like stress
right at the beginning that obviously
I'm talking about incremental skills
that's where my bias is going to show
but I don't want you to consider these
as like good versus bad I think each has
its value
I just want to compare them and contrast
them so if this is like incremental
skill this is what appliance looks like
to me and basically it's not a spectrum
there's like huge gaps that require like
lots of activation energy either like
you know personally actually really
wanting to do something or you know
might be just expensive to take the next
step or whatever and I think like a good
example of this is a microwave nothing
you really learn from a microwave kind
of sets you on the path to being a cook
right like learning the buttons does not
prepare you for anything like learning
that you shouldn't put metal in there
doesn't really have like overriding
implications at least I don't think so I
hope not so if we think of like cooking
is kind of this appliance model you know
somewhere between you know my mom makes
me food and like I'm cooking a
five-course meal the microwave is
somewhere in the middle but it's not
very smoothly in the middle you know
using postmates sit somewhere in the
middle to but if you want to take the
next step to actually cook you're
probably gonna have to buy a whole bunch
of new tools and learn a whole bunch of
unrelated things right
and so I just want to quickly give you
my nightmare scenario which is what
programming may look like in the future
which is you know you're given an iPad
congratulations you know daddy's rich
you have things to say so you download
the medium app and you start you know
saying whatever and then I don't know by
some miracle I guess you become
interested in programming and then you
shell out another $2,000 for a different
kind of computer that requires all sorts
of different like learning curves and
then you pay under $99 to get like a
developer account and then your
programming I guess so I think that in
the iOS world programming feels a lot
more like an appliance where like the
the things you download and use don't
really fit in a kind of bigger learning
spectrum they have like a very very
focused goal and then if you want to
program it's very divided like you
have to have that like kind of personal
initiation to like say I want to do this
and like start learning it and I don't
want to really want to like this isn't
like an iOS versus the web thing because
kind of the point of my talk is that I
feel that a very similar thing is
happening to the web today and not for
bad reasons like everything is happening
for kind of a good reason in
particularly like you know again I was
saying like when I was started
programming like live journals like kind
of the way you did things and now I
think what's happened is we've made the
easy stuff way easier right like medium
comm is way easier to use in like oh you
have to learn kind of HTML or something
I think no one can deny that you know
WYSIWYG editors are better for just like
writing long-form text like you
shouldn't have to learn HTML to write
long-form text right and then the other
thing that's happened is all those
things is that I've kind of described
his benefits of like early HTML we're
also kind of hindrances right like we
really cleaned HTML up and we made it a
lot better we made the technologies much
more powerful so we've made the hard
stuff way harder and like you know my
dad could figure out like font color
equals red but I don't think he really
knows what a span is like what's a span
and like span style equals color : right
like all that stuff is way harder right
and like definitely setting up like a
node.js server is way harder than PHP
and like if you want to take a coat of
met CAD amia class again you have to
sign up you have to decide I am becoming
a programmer right so all this stuff is
good it's just that I feel that the web
is becoming more like this appliance
model where there's now this kind of big
gap and I don't think people are kind of
building these kind of in-between skills
where they may end up kind of
accidentally becoming a programmer like
I did and I think that's fine as long as
we fill in that gap right and the reason
I originally named this talk you know
the browser is not feature complete is
that I really feel that the browser is
what can fill in this gap and so to kind
of explain what I mean by that I just
want to give you a really super concise
and narrowly focused history of the
browser
again that's netscape seven and this was
kind of like peak browser feature this
browser had an email client a news
client a mail client sorry like a
netscape male versus like normal email
an address book an IRC client and it had
ill and some messenger built in it had
radio built in right it had all sorts of
things and generally people decided this
was a bad thing this was like was a
super slow browser it was really clumsy
it was it was pretty bad and so the
response to that was phoenix which was
later renamed Firefox I think for legal
reasons or something but the response
was to say hey it's a browser it just
meant to browse things not like I don't
know listen to radio and like talk on
AOL and stuff let's make the content
shine let's focus on engine stuff versus
browser features so you know again we
made html5 and JavaScript we better we
added all sorts of really cool developer
tools to again help the core of the
browsing experience as opposed to all
the surrounding stuff you know we had
things like chrome which did the multi
process stuff and we started even
considering all sorts of cool new
technologies and I think this kind of
set the pace of where like the way we
think about the browser was headed for a
long time up until today right you can
definitely see this with you know mobile
safari this is what it looked like in
the original version and this is what it
looks like now and as you can see we've
kind of like get that browser out of
there right like let's just have the
content and that's even more true like
in a rotating motor like there's no
browser at all finally finally got rid
of the browser right like we can finally
look at just the website and this is
also true of desktop right and this is
really interesting when you start to
think of the browser this way is this
like basically Minimum Viable browser
right it's particularly interesting
because it adds kind of a new layer of
understanding to a discussion that was
like very prevalent the last time I
spoke at J's compeers ago which was
Native versus web if you kind of think
of the browser is not doing anything
anything above like just delivering the
website correctly it makes this
kind of a really tough argument for the
website right like you end up with like
these really abstract reasons for why
the web is better like it's open right
it's kept harping it's open it so it
doesn't really mean anything to like a
user you also end up with kind of like
developer reasons like oh hey like you
know I can ship to every single platform
really easily it's you know that's not
it's such a great user reason either
where it's like the native arguments are
really obvious like it's way faster
right it looks like it looks like it
fits into the rest of your OS and not
only that but you can make a bunch of
money if you do it right like so what I
remember pretty clearly is that really
unfortunately the argument became open
versus good which was always gonna be a
losing argument and that sucks because
that's never the reason I really like
the web like I don't particularly care
about those abstract reasons let me tell
you what I like the web and let me do
that through a series of native
experiences I've had
this is iPad right I'm looking for a
drawing app because I don't know the new
pencils coming out and this is what I
get so every time I want to look at a
different app I get this like horrible
mobile modal experience that have to
keep going back and forth in and if I
just had like tabs so I could like open
them all up and then later if I want to
do a different search I don't lose these
and I can come back to them that would
be pretty cool it's too bad we have to
wait for this programmer to implement
them on their own and if you notice
something else these are just like the
worst search results possible right like
none of like Adobe sketch isn't there I
couldn't possibly be interested in the
most popular drawing a bright no
wouldn't it be cool if like the way an
iPad app was fundamentally made was
semantic so that you could put two
different kinds of apps together one
could understand the other and the one
that focuses really well on search could
give you way better search results I
guess we just have to wait until Apple
gets really good at search so to Spotify
and you know rocking out to Jurassic
world had that thing you know just
non-stop for a while so I'm really
curious about the songs I was listening
to before
because again I just had everything on
repeat so I'm not really sure we're like
the history is so step one is of course
I go into the forum and I find like how
to look at the songs I listen to well
you click on that uh triple equals
button or something
I think it's an homage to JavaScript and
then you click on history but joke's on
you it only goes back fifty items so
since you've been listening to lost
world this whole time you're never gonna
know right wouldn't it be cool if there
was like a system history where I could
decide how long and how far back it goes
that way it's not up to me somehow
making a feature request to please make
it go from fifty to a hundred or
something ridiculous right
here's another experience I'm on the
Apple Store or in the App Store sorry
and I really want to share this app with
someone else give them a hint that maybe
they should buy it for me I know not
really sure how to do that it's well if
you look hard enough you'll see that if
you click there there's a copy link
button or share on Twitter sure to
Facebook I have no idea what
tell-a-friend does no idea but what if
you could use your existing skills to
kind of copy something that you could
send to someone so you don't have to
like always be finding the unique way to
share with every particular app right or
here's another idea my grandma called me
and she really wants to know how to get
to her albums in iPhoto I really really
wish I could just respond with hey just
click that okay so leave me alone
just if you click that it'll take you to
your albums or even better if there was
like some sort of like system
intelligent find where my grandma could
just type in albums and even if it's a
UI item like it still would show up in
the find that you wouldn't even have to
call me right these are the reasons I
like the web write this stuff it's it's
not really like JavaScript right or HTML
like those things are great but that's
not really what makes the web the web in
my opinion it's these things are kind of
like incremental skills and these aren't
new ideas right like the whole idea
behind discoverability was this right
like that there are things that you put
in the people can discover that then pay
dividends forever afterwards
and in fact there are some things that
are so important right when we were
first making like UI computers that we
said we shouldn't even leave it up to
the application makers they should be at
the system level right like if we handle
copy paste then we make sure you only
have to learn copy paste once right if
we handle like the way you organize apps
you only have to learn that once if you
learn files and you can like use apps
together and I really fundamentally
believe that you know it's been 30 years
since we came up with these original
concepts that we can graduate and kind
of add this new layer I think that in
the past 30 years we've observed how
people want to use computers and the
fundamentals that the browser gives you
really handle these new behaviors really
well right like people want to share
stuff right it should things should be
shareable by default not if you happen
to put the share button in right like
people really want to be able to like
kind of duplicate their screen
everything should have tabs it shouldn't
be up to like us to implement tabs right
like fine should just work across
everything whether it's a button or
whether it's content and the really cool
thing about like kind of this this
proposal of these kind of like behaviors
that sit in between here is that they
all fundamentally rely on these two core
technologies plain text delivery and the
URL right how does history work it just
keeps a list of URLs how does searching
history work well it keeps a list of
URLs and it can search the plain text
right like how does find in page work
well thankfully since it's plain text
you can find it right and this is what I
think makes a web the web right like if
we had like shipped the web using s
expressions instead of HTML and Python
instead of JavaScript the web would
still be the web because of this so I
think there's like a big problem and
everything I'm saying right or Elif in
the room or something if it's true that
these things are so amazing right the
history and tabs and everything then why
aren't people kind of missing it right
why don't people miss it when they go
and use the native thing right do you
guys remember when we first got the
first iPhone it didn't have copy/paste
and you were like staring at your phone
at this piece of text and thinking to
yourself am i honestly can have to
memorize this like a cave
and then retype it into text messages
like they were livid and so we got copy
paste why aren't people like crying out
for history why aren't people crying out
for tabs right so what idea is that
oh you know maybe since it's we went
from like desktop to mobile these like
ideas don't really make that much sense
never I don't think that's true right
like I think the proliferation of the
send box to heaven button should be a
clear indication that people want
sharing in all these things so I think
the reason people aren't clamoring for
these features is that you know I just
sat here and gave you this very ideal
view of like history and stuff but the
reality is that's what history actually
looks like right it's it's horrible it's
like it's like if you're a cocoa
programmer you know that this is
literally taking a tableview dragging it
and thank God they remembered to resize
it to fit the window because that's
about all the work they did right and if
I do a search which is buried at the
bottom right oh hey 3,000 matches was
that full-text search just to just title
and I don't know you figure it out you
bought the computer I don't know like
the only incremental skill to learn here
is to remember to delete your history
before you give it to someone else right
like that's it if you just think about
it for half a second right like it's
crazy we live in an era where quite
possibly the smartest minds are as we
speak working on determining your
browsing behavior right the NSA is p's
ads and even the college I go to knows
more about my browsing history than I do
and that's a whole nother discussion
whether they should be like snooping on
me or not whatever that's a different
discussion but at least at least if
you're gonna have all this data on me
make it available to me at least let me
also have a chance to like be able to
search for my history in a good way
right so I wouldn't want to give you an
alternative view of what history could
be like and so it's kind of just a quick
redesign and this isn't so important
right now the big the ideas here just
like hey we don't need to see eight
hundred items in one page right Google
doesn't do that you only need to see a
couple you can scroll to see the rest
it'd be really nice if I could actually
see the page and have a good idea that
it's full text search or whatever but
this isn't like the biggest deal so
again there there you go the big deal
for me is once you have like a really
great foundation for history you can
start doing this kind of composition
right so the one I'm really interested
is is you know composing html5 with
history so I was looking at this really
awesome making of Jurassic world thing
because it puts together the best things
ever dinosaurs and computers and I this
happens to me a lot I could sworn I've
seen this video but what I do search for
it it doesn't come up right and the way
searches you know addresses world
YouTube because that's where probably
saw it now the browser knows what sites
have videos right that's a point of
semantic stuff right the video tag so
why not record when a site has video so
then I can make a more reasonable kind
of search right I can do something like
this and oh that's why I didn't come up
cuz it was a Vimeo site and I don't take
the time to memorize the different
brands right so if the browser knows
about video tags it can expose that to
me in a way that's more incremental
right and lets me know that it has some
sort of knowledge about video without
having me know necessarily about html5
right and again
the browser also knows a bunch of
semantic information so let's just go
ahead and show you the poster images so
I don't have to play Where's Waldo with
this thing right and you can do the kind
of the same thing with audio right if
you have audio tags that's even more
powerful in my opinion because it's much
more likely that you're listening to
lots of different audio sources and so I
was listening to a song I don't really
know the name so I don't put a search
thing in there I just select music and
of course I just get like the songs I
listen to again determined by the audio
tag in descending order of time and
again the really cool thing about a
semantic is that information is that it
knows where the file lives right so why
not make that available to me and just
let me play them right and just store
the string URL and now I can kind of
search the music by sound instead of
having to try to remember the name of
the song or whatever which again it's
probably not very likely because things
just play and just go to the next song
or whatever so I feel as if history
looked something more like that then you
would all of a sudden start seeing
people who missed history when you went
to native write like they'd say hey I
was listening to music in these three
different iOS apps and I want to know
what song it is I now think it's
ridiculous that I have to open up three
iOS apps and check all three which is
the way we felt with copy-paste where we
said hey I had a good solution for copy
paste now I don't anymore right and in
my opinion I think the discussion would
be more mirrored where like it would be
more trade off II like hey you know with
native you might get fast but you don't
get all these other nice features and
more importantly I think that that gives
you the opportunity to build these Pro
users right I can't really go to my dad
and try to get him on board with like
the audio tag or the video tag is it
mean anything to him he doesn't care
however if in his music search one of
the results doesn't have a play button
because it uses flash from music instead
of you know the audio tag he will get
upset and possibly tell the site hey
your site's broken it doesn't work here
right this is what I mean by the kind of
like the benefit of these Pro users
you've just created a secret html5
advocate without him knowing it he's
starting to build this idea that the web
works in certain ways and again that may
have different returns he may just go
and complain to the site but he may also
go and try to help the site implement
that like I've seen that happen right
like if you look at cocoa apps like
people really like to go and write the
localization files for people is it any
surprise that the only open part of a
cocoa app write the localization file is
the one that people actually contribute
to in droves and I think like a really
good example of that is this site
wanting Connie if you want to check it
out it's for learning Japanese but they
built it in such a way that it's like
really tink horrible and people have
gone and made just like thousands of
different apps for it and if you go read
the forum's like all the comments are or
many of these are hey I've never
programmed before but I really had this
H I wanted to scratch and this was kind
of easy too
back around and I was able to build this
again HyperCard very much had that idea
right like every app was like
fundamentally editable you got an app
and you could like change the behaviors
of the buttons and we kind of get that
for free with the web right you can
inspect an element and kind of start
understanding how it works and I think
this was also the original vision of the
web like if you look at and that's skate
for it came with an editor built-in
right and if you look at the original
idea of the web it was for scientists to
share right like the idea of shipping a
browser that couldn't edit documents was
kind of like shipping Microsoft Word
without letting you edit like it was
only doing half its job and I think it's
really unfortunate that the web is
becoming more read-only in my opinion
and that's kind of the reason I wanted
to give a talk here at JSC um
because every one to you is a creator
right and that makes you part of a
really cool Club and as a creator you
have a lot more influence than you think
either in the apps you create yourself
like in the example of one Akane they
built it in a way that actually inspires
our users to kind of become creators
themselves or just in the things you
choose to you know request out of your
browser right like we are the ones who
come up with new ideas for browser
features and go and bug the developers
right usually it's not them like average
user and I think that in our community
we have kind of this general sense that
we'd like this club of creators to be
bigger I certainly feel that way I know
I wish I could talk to my dad about the
things I do more and I feel that back
then I actually had a better chance of
getting stuff across to him because
again he was like actually building
sites and stuff back then and now he
feels like he's very separate from that
it's like Oh something I have to learn
right and I think that's a really sad
transition to make I think if we start
kind of thinking about this way of
teaching stuff this incremental way as
opposed to kind of these first-order
approaches like oh how do we make
programming languages easier or how do
we teach a class or whatever instead we
kind of think about how can we make the
environment itself like more
fundamentally incremental it starts to
inform a lot of other discussions we
have that we never really thought had
anything to do with teaching programming
like a really good example
good UI like we talked a lot about good
UI like Oh flat vs. scheme or fake or
you know fits law but good UI doesn't
really mean anything unless you know
what it's good for right and so if you
ask yourself when you're building an app
or you're building your browser like am
I trying to build an appliance is this
like a one-off am I trying to build
something that is basically for a user
that's at the end of their journey right
like they've come in and they're gonna
do this one task and then they're gonna
leave and that's it that that means kind
of a very different kind of UI then if
you're building something more like a
calculator which is something that's at
the beginning or the middle of your
users journey right and that's it thank
you